Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Ten: Danish science and thinking.
Research and innovation are today one of the basic preconditions of the Danish economy and thereby Danish welfare.
Danish research takes place to a large extent at the Danish universities, but research is also done at, for example, university hospitals, museums, libraries and archives.
In addition, a lot of research takes place in private business.
Especially within medicine, biochemistry and technology, Denmark is internationally known for its research.
Danish research at an international level has roots far back in time.
Several Danish scientists have over time helped shape international scientific development.
One of the first Danish scientists was the astronomer Tycho Brahe, who lived from 1546 to 1601, a nobleman from Skåne, who in 1559 came to Copenhagen to study at the university.
He was mathematically gifted, constructed astronomical instruments and made the until then most precise mapping of the starry sky.
One of Tycho Brahe's great achievements was to discover a new star, Nova Stella, in the constellation Cassiopeia.
Tycho Brahe's observations became important not least because the world-famous German astronomer Johannes Kepler, who lived from 1571 to 1630, used them to shape his groundbreaking laws about how the planets move around the sun.
Niels Steensen, who lived from 1638 to 86, also contributed to science in the 1600s.
Like Tycho Brahe, he did not accept the established explanations, but put emphasis on his own observations.
Niels Steensen was trained as a doctor and travelled to the Netherlands, where he made important discoveries within anatomy, that is the structure of the body.
Among other things, he was the first to show how we cry, and further that the heart is a muscle and not, as had until then often been believed, the home of the soul and feelings.
The astronomer and physicist Ole Rømer, who lived from 1644 to 1710, made an important scientific discovery when in 1676 he found out that light had "a hesitation", that is, that it does not spread immediately, but moves with a given speed from source to receiver.
Later he described new methods for measuring weight and distance.
He also did the preparatory work to get the present, Gregorian, calendar introduced in Denmark in the year 1700.
Until the beginning of the 1700s, it was not known whether Asia and North America were connected by land.
To explore this question, the Russian tsar, emperor, Peter the Great sent out in 1725 an expedition led by the Danish naval officer and explorer Vitus Bering, who lived from 1681 to 1741.
In 1728, Vitus Bering's expedition succeeded in sailing up through the strait that separates Siberia and Alaska, and thereby proved that Asia and North America are separated by water.
Some years later Vitus Bering returned as leader of a new and even bigger expedition that was to map Alaska's coast.
On the way home the expedition was stranded on a small deserted island off Russia's east coast, where it had to overwinter in extreme cold and without wood for heating.
Many died, including Vitus Bering himself.
He is buried on the island, which today bears his name, Bering Island, just as the sea it lies in is called the Bering Sea, and the strait that separates Siberia and Alaska is called the Bering Strait.
In 1820, the physicist H.C.
Ørsted, who lived from 1777 to 1851, discovered that electric current produces magnetism, the so-called electromagnetism.
A connection between electricity and magnetism had already been described by the Italian philosopher Romagnosi in 1802, but Ørsted's work was more profound and gained spread in scientific circles.
The discovery of electromagnetism laid the foundation for the technological use of electricity in society and production.
It was also his ambition to make natural science accessible and understandable to a larger part of the population.
Among other things, he made an effort to give scientific concepts and terms Danish words.
For example, he came up with the words ilt and brint instead of the foreign words oxygen and hydrogen.
Denmark has also made its mark internationally within philosophy.
That is first and foremost due to Søren Kierkegaard, who lived from 1813 to 55.
In his 42 years of life he managed to write a series of significant works within philosophy, theology, psychology and poetry.
Enten – Eller, "Either/Or", from 1843, is one of his most important works.
Søren Kierkegaard is regarded as the founder of existentialist philosophy, which assumes that every human being becomes who they are through the choices they make.
In the middle of the 1800s, ideas about women's liberation and equality between the sexes were formulated by the author Mathilde Fibiger, who lived from 1830 to 1872, who published the epistolary novel Clara Raphael.
Tolv Breve, "Twelve Letters", in 1851.
The book became the occasion for an extensive dispute among authors, artists and politicians about women's role in society, and she inspired the organised women's movement which grew up from the 1870s.
Contrary to the ideals of the time about marriage, Mathilde Fibiger never married but was employed as a telegraphist at the Danish State Telegraph as Denmark's first female civil servant.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
Which Danish scientist is known for discovering electromagnetism?
Option A: Niels Bohr.
Option B: Ole Rømer.
Option C: H.C.
Ørsted.
[DA] Hvilken dansk videnskabsmand er kendt for opdagelsen af elektromagnetismen?  A: Niels Bohr  |  B: Ole Rømer  |  C: H.C. Ørsted
The answer is C: H.C.
Ørsted.
It appeared in the June 2020 exam.
[DA] ✔ C: H.C. Ørsted
Question 2.
When did the philosopher Søren Kierkegaard live?
Option A: In the 1700s.
Option B: In the 1800s.
Option C: In the 1900s.
[DA] Hvornår levede filosoffen Søren Kierkegaard?  A: I 1700-tallet  |  B: I 1800-tallet  |  C: I 1900-tallet
The answer is B: In the 1800s.
It appeared in the June 2020 and May 2025 exams.
[DA] ✔ B: I 1800-tallet
Question 3.
What is Vitus Bering especially known for?
Option A: He was a philosopher.
Option B: He was an explorer.
Option C: He was a composer.
[DA] Hvad er Vitus Bering særligt kendt for?  A: Han var filosof  |  B: Han var opdagelsesrejsende  |  C: Han var komponist
The answer is B: He was an explorer.
It appeared in the November 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ B: Han var opdagelsesrejsende
Question 4.
What is Tycho Brahe, 1546 to 1601, especially known for?
Option A: He was an astronomer.
Option B: He was a hymn writer.
Option C: He was an explorer.
[DA] Hvad er Tycho Brahe (1546-1601) særlig kendt for?  A: Han var astronom  |  B: Han var salmedigter  |  C: Han var opdagelsesrejsende
The answer is A: He was an astronomer.
It appeared in the November 2024 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Han var astronom
That's the end of Part One of Episode 10.
In Part Two, we continue with Danish science in more recent times.
See you there.